for that Duck Dynasty guy I know what he  said was wrong but I don't get the shock  said that homophobic stuff he's like you  can you believe yeah I totally can  believe it that [ __ ] kind of [ __ ]  that that homophobic stuff that all  comes from the church Manchester they  just [ __ ] brainwash it say what we  what we say it  all right I'll say  I'll say it again  how can I go on to my toys you get on  with your life events the new Duck  whistle yours goes quiet mine goes where  I [ __ ] work he's loving life and out  of nowhere here comes that same question  60 years later  phone he stands up like The Manchurian  Candidate Jesus likes hookers and lepers  doesn't like to queer  and everybody freaks the [ __ ] out  he's like  we're dead and they're all dead oh  where'd everybody go